الى السعوديه احدث مقطع فيديو جدلا عبر
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي يظهر فيه اب
سعودي يقوم بتحضير الحليب لطفل رضيع اما
دفع هذا المقطع لتصدر تراند ووجود هذا
الاب وسط مجلس رجالي في احدى المناسبات
ومن هنا وهناك انهمرت التعليقات والنقاشات
حول المقطع البعض يرى ان تصرف الرجل
طبيعيا جدا ولا ينقص شيئا من رجولته في
المقابل انتقد البعض الاب الشام
يعني الفيديو الذي انتشر انتشارا كبيرا
وانت تحضر فيه الحليب لابنك وسط مجلس
رجالي اولا ما رايك بهذا التفاعل الكبير
مع هذا الفيديو
من كميه التفاعل اللي صارت على المقطع
خصوصا مقطع كان بين اصدقائي يعني ما كان
المقطع
متوقع انه ينتشر بهذه الطريقه في همم
المقطع كان بين اصدقاء انا حطيته في تيك
توك
وانتشر خذ انتشار ما اقدر السيطر عليه
يعني حتى كنت ناوي احذفه في البدايه لان
همم الصوره اللي اخذت على المقطع غلط
ما كنا في وسط المعجل بس همم
الكبار الولد
نعم بس حسن يعني واضح عليك كثير مرتاح
وانت بتعد الحليب يعني كانه هيك مش اول
مره اسلوب حياه عندك انت من مناصريه
مساعده الزوجات وانه المراه والرجال واحد
يعني في تربيه الابناء انا ما اعتقد ان
الموضوع ان انا جالس اساعد همم الزوجه
وقاعد اساعد
احد انا قاعد سعد ولد في النهايه هو
بولدها هي بس ولد همم
ما ساعدت احد انا غير ولدي
اصيله لفتويه حنونه لكن بعد الثاني والقسم
الثاني اعتبرها انها تقلل من احترام
المجلس الرجالي كيف ترد عليه
[موسيقى]
الموضوع طبيعي جدا الواحد همم يشربه يمكن
تحضير الحليب همم
هو اللي كان اييي مشهد غير مقلوف
وهو كان محضر حليب من البدايه وخلص ما
اقدر اروح الدجاج
وعلى العموم ما كان في وسط المجلس مثل ما
قلت لك في البدايه كان في نهايه المجلس
وكنا احنا جالسين شباب مع بعض طيب حسن بعد
الانتقادات وبعد التعليقات اللي كانت على
مواقع التواصل وبعد الانتشار الكبير اللي
اثار الجدل لهذا المقطع هل انت مستعد مره
ثانيه تاخذ ابنك معك على مجلس رجالي وتحضر
له الحليب يا حسن
همم
يعني ما بحضر للحليب او باسوي له نفس
الطريقه لانه ما بيكون لافتات
يعني هو الولد له خصوصيه والولد له همم
المفروض ما يكون بهالشكل الناس الطالع
يعني الموضوع كان طبيعي في البدايه الحين
الموضوع ما صار طبيعي فما افضل
وانا اسوي الحليب يمكن اخذ معي اكيد هو
ولدي وانا ابيع على يمين على طول
[موسيقى]